how's it going everybody so we haven't
heard much about Captain Marvel lately
the teaser trailer came out and then it
all kind of went quiet for a little bit
we know that they're doing reshoots
right now but besides that not much has
really been happening but that ended
when we got these leaked official promo
art photos of Captain Marvel wearing her
Mohawk helmet this is really cool it
looks really awesome and a lot of people
were worried that she wasn't really
going to wear this in the movie we did
get a tiny little glimpse of this in the
trailer however she wasn't wearing her
Captain Marvel uniform when she had the
helmet on she was wearing her green Kree
uniform so the fear here was that she's
only going to wear the helmet when she's
a part of Star Force and Star Force is
the Kree military unit that she is with
but thanks to this leak we see her
wearing it with her Captain Marvel
uniform the coolest thing about her
wearing the helmet with her Captain
Marvel uniform is that it completes a
comic accurate uniform which is
something that can always go terribly
wrong
especially with Captain Marvel we know
that it's not going to be a traditional
origin story but since Captain Marvel is
supposed to be the strongest superhero
in the MCU when she comes into play I'm
sure they're doing everything they can
to make this movie absolutely amazing
now obviously she won't be wearing it
the whole entire movie just like she
doesn't wear it all of the time in the
comics but it is a really cool note to
throw in there to the comics I love the
helmet I love that it's really really
comic accurate and I love the mohawk
I've always thought that that was a
really cool thing about the helmet her
hair just kind of goes out of the top
forming that mohawk so it's really cool
to see it in this concept art and I
really look forward to seeing it in the
movie maybe we'll even get a glimpse of
it in the next trailer but until then
let me know what you think of this new
concept art for Captain Marvel wearing
her Mohawk helmet and as always my
giveaway continues giving away copies of
Infinity Ward the art of the movie art
book along with copies of infinity war
Deadpool 2 or Ant Man and the wasp on
blu-ray as well as some special edition
posters if you'd like to enter for your
chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero be
sure to come back for more videos on
Captain Marvel Avengers 4 and all things
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]